un accord de taxation historique ce
vendredi 136 pays et représentant 90% du
pib mondial ont obtenu un accord sur la
taxation des multinationales
prochainement taxés à hauteur de 15% sur
leurs bénéfices cet accord jugé
historique par ses partisans vise
notamment à freiner l'évasion fiscale
cela devrait engager 150 milliards
d'euros de recettes supplémentaires on
va en parler tout de suite avec nos
invités jean paul zhang spécialiste en
économie cofondateur de la lettre de
l'est de chine et frédéric boccara
économiste et membre des économistes
atterrés
bonsoir à messieurs merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france
concrètement qu'est ce qui va changer à
partir à 2023 jean-paul change
vraiment les gars ça en principe donc
les grandes multinationales le numérique
américaines vont être taxés à 15% ont
parlé jusqu'à maintenant de 15% minima
le taux minimal de 15 % cette année 15%
voilà qu'à 75%
pour les autres multinationales
on s'est demandé si ces 15% va pas
devenir finalement un taux qui va être
une norme à poser finalement parlé et a
faim donc c'est ça et dans l'application
toute façon les rapaces que suivant les
pays qui ont signé à sa peine d'un pays
à obtenir des exemptions ici et là donc
il reste il reste encore voir dans la
pratique si c'est vraiment historique et
si c'est vraiment quel logiciel voilà
justement enfin gilles boquérat 15% à
d'imposition pour les multinationales
c'est à peu près aux normes de ce que
l'on peut voir dans certains pays qui
sont considérés comme des paradis
fiscaux fin vous allez nous dire est ce
que ça peut vraiment lutter cette cette
mesure contre
vision fiscale
alors merci bonsoir oui effectivement
vous avez raison de souligner les choses
d'abord ça cet accord illustre le besoin
d'accord international de coopération
internationale et de se parler mais
effectivement
le pinceau c'est un taux de dumping
fiscal en france le taux affiché est de
30%
donc ça pose un problème deuxièmement il
ya un brouillard de fumée alors à 15% et
puis ces vastes à y aurait plus rien à
faire il faudrait juste appliqué les 15%
mais en réalité se pose deux problèmes
d'abord les multinationales ne pose pas
seulement comme problème de faire évader
de l'argent qui empêche les impôts donc
de diminuer les recettes fiscales le
premier des multinationales c'est pas
seulement de transférer leurs résultats
dans les paradis fiscaux mais c'est
aussi leur type de résultat aux
guillemets leur contribution à l'emploi
aux recherches aux libertés avec les
données au développement des biens
communs aux investissements donc
derrière ça en réalité pour être
vraiment révolutionnaire pour reprendre
le mot de monsieur zhang d'ailleurs le
titre c'est à dire pour changer les
choses telles que les gens le voudrait
aujourd'hui il faudrait se préoccuper de
l'utilisation de l'argent par les
multinationales et donc tout un ensemble
de pouvoir nouveau sur l'utilisation de
l'argent ou d'orientations nouvelles sur
l'utilisation de l'argent par le crédit
par des ddd l'information et les
pouvoirs de la société civile et
travailleurs des citoyens et par des
coopérations internationales ou des
accords internationaux nouveau
de nous tous trop cheap que les accords
comme le taffetas d accord qui vise le
développement des biens communs
et la coopération internationale c'est
tout à fait possible mais aujourd'hui
avec ce 15% on a un peu un brouillard de
fumées
épaisses 15% en paix et 400 bon c'est
pas c'est pas ça qui va qui va changer
les choses malheureusement mais ça
montre le besoin de changer jean-paul
chang est ce qu'à votre avis justement
ce nouvel accord avec à 15% de taxation
pour les multinationales ça va les
empêcher d'aller vers des paradis
fiscaux
alors en ce qui concerne les paradis
fiscaux c'est vrai que cette décision
important un coup fatal au château de
paradis fiscaux ces messieurs alignable
assure qu'il ya plus de
deux régions finalement si effectivement
celle 15% qui s'applique partout
donc là dessus sur sur les paradis
fiscaux où il rend en effet
que certains concerts de salutaire mais
deuxièmement c'est la taxation s'est pas
seulement à tôt c'est aussi évidemment
la base
comme disait
notre autre invité là c'est la cedr a
effectivement comment se répartissent
ensuite les les les bases qui servent à
attaque c'est ça qu'est bon il ya un
deuxième pilier dans les accords
concernant effectivement des miss
nationale dans le chiffre d'affaires est
très supérieure à 20
north bay
on a des petits soucis de livres
nous entendons là des petits soucis de
liaison à laisser continuer oui oui je
l'entends oui donc effectivement le les
paradis fiscaux c'est une chose bon bien
sûr il y aura un effet ces paradis
fiscaux mais ça n'empêchera pas ce qu'on
appelle l'optimisation fiscale
finalement de la part des
multinationales
parce que encore une fois
ce n'est qu'un taux et il faut aussi
voir qui est la base d'imposition est
commencée répartir ensuite par exemple
des chiffres d'affaires les bénéfices
et comment ça serait parti finalement
par région un pays et c'est donc
l'optimisation fiscale va continuer de
la part du mythe national
même si les paradis fiscaux vont prendre
un coup
alors frédéric boccara on l'a vu ces
derniers jours plusieurs pays en europe
l'irlande l'estonie la hongrie ou encore
la pologne ont rejoint l'accord qu'est
ce qui a finalement poussé ces pays en
europe à le faire
je pense qu'il ya plusieurs choses qui
s'entremêlent d'abord comme je voulais
dit il ya vraiment une pression des
opinions parce que il ya un véritable
scandale en réalité
les multinationales
c'est les gens qui travaillent dedans
qui créent les richesses quand même et
ses richesses c'est le résultat même si
on peut discuter comme je l'aï dit tout
à l'heure ses résultats de leur
orientation d'activités en tout cas ces
résultats leur échappe pour une partie
alors on est le lac sans le projecteur
sur le fait que ce qui échappe aux ans
c'est les revenus possibles pour les
états les impôts la fiscalité prélever
ces multinationales et donc les états se
sont tenus de faire quelque chose mais
ce qui échappe aussi c'est des salaires
et des cotisations sociales c'est des
investissements possibles c'est beaucoup
de choses donc les pays rejoigne parce
qu'il ya une pression chez eux dans leur
opinion et puis probablement ya une
inquiétude quand même d'évasion de
matière fiscale donc on cherche tous les
morceaux mais attention avec la
définition de paradis fiscal l'atr par
exemple en france quand on regarde et
attentionné que 15 % quand on regarde en
france ont fait le rapport entre eux ce
que rapporte l'impôt sur les sociétés
l'impôt sur les bénéfices
et le total des bénéfices bruts des
entreprises calculé par l'insee le b e
on trouve un taux effectif non pas un
taux facial affiché mais un taux
effectif de 8,6 pour cent
donc ce 15% comme l'a souligné après moi
monsieur chang
tous qui assiègent fiscale va fondre et
donc y aura 15 % sur une assiette qui
sera très précis donc peut-être qu'un
certain nombre de pays ne seront pas
gênés en tout cas toute la négociation
va continuer je prends un exemple la
france fait partie des paradis fiscaux
pour ce qui est des taxations des
recettes de brevets pour les recettes de
brevets la france ne taxent qu'à 10% au
lieu de 31% sur le reste des bénéfices
donc dans un bénéfice de 106 vous avez
50 de brevets ils seront taxés à 10%
donc vraiment l'enjeu avec cette
révolution informationnelle pourquoi ça
monte cette question parce qu'on a la
crise parce qu'on manque de recettes
parce qu'il faudrait développer les
services publics mais parce que les
changements profonds il ya une
révolution informationnelle avec
l'information qui peut se transférer
voyez par exemple le le la formule pour
refaire le doliprane de plus sur du
papier simplement elle peut être
utilisés simultanément dans tous les
pays à la fois et être sur les
différentes machines d filiale de sanofi
pour ne pas le citer et donc ça
fonctionne comme un acteur global comme
un mondial allait donc l'enjeu c'est
comme on organise le partage
l'utilisation et le développement des
biens communs et c'est ça qui devrait
être à l'ordre du jour du débat avec des
nouveaux traités internationaux nouvelle
organisation du monde chine etats unis
europe cédé qu'en d'afrique est des
grandes questions on veut éviter et
comprend par la bande tant mieux sur les
prend par la bande il va falloir
vraiment vraiment élargir le cas des
transports de garder les choses cissé
c'est la compétitivité des
multinationales des entreprises jean
paul chambre en pleine guerre
commerciale avec la chine que vous
connaissez bien justement cet accord que
dont les partisans jugent justement
historique visa devrait dégager 150
milliards d'euros
qu'est ce que ça va avoir comme
conséquence justement sur les économies
mondiales d'un point de vue global si
l'on vous
écoutez ça veut dire que les finances
publiques des différents pays vont avoir
effectivement des cours supplémentaires
estimé à 150 milliards de deux heures à
partir de 2023 reste à savoir si vous
voulez est ce que ses proches qu'il est
quand même très moraliste sous
l'impulsion beaucoup de français qui
travaillent en ocde peu sous la pression
de l'opinion publique en effet aussi est
ce que c'est une approche qui est
vraiment gêné dire
totale parce que finalement quand on
parle de recettes fiscales
grc comme très curieux alors j'essaie de
le prendre à un tout petit peu des
distances en disant écoutez dans la
finance publique il ya certes les
recettes que tous les états cherche de
l'argent partout c'est normal mais aussi
des dépenses mais aussi les dépenses
alors il faut savoir que ses impôts ne
servent pas simplement par exemple
aux investissements ou à leur
description et c est aussi et des
dépenses militaires et autres et c'est
donc moi j'ai toujours trouvé très
curieux personnellement que on ne peut
avoir de ophain connaît une approche
aussi morale finalement sur le problème
de recettes sans qu'on parle jamais
finalement en
2d pense donc qu'il ya beaucoup de
dépenses qui sont peut-être aussi
assujettis à des réflexions morales
voilà c'est ça que je veux dire c'est
bon c'est ça le creux marre que je fais
autre moi
en tant mieux au poney et finances
publiques du boxer ça c'est pour les
finances publiques donc les les 150
milliards d'euros mais s'agissant des
multinationales jean-paul chang
justement dans cette guerre commerciale
que l'on connaît avec des pays européens
mais mes états unis avec calèche
oui bah écoutez les les les chinois ont
l'équivalent un peu dégâts femmes en
effet les eaux comme tencent et c'est
pas bon
alibaba entre autres il est clair que
ces entreprises bénéficient aussi de
l'absence de taxation de ce plan
international et tout ceci dit on est
déjà remarqué que même le gouvernement
chinois a pris en plus n'avancent pas
repose au comblement dans dans la
réglementation concernant ces grandes
entreprises pour casser les monopoles
pour les fait rentrer finalement sous la
supervision des différentes commissions
de contrôle que ce soit en matière
bancaire
ou boursière et c'est donc je vois pas
pour le moment je ne vois pas du tout le
compte d'élections entre le fait que les
chinois aient adhéré à cet accord
d'ailleurs si j'ai même rencontré des
experts chinois qui ont travaillé à
l'eau ces deux justement sur ce sujet
depuis quelques années déjà et donc ce
n'est pas au niveau des entreprises d'un
compétitives les entreprises de mieux
que ça va se jouer sachant que ces
personnes en tout cas femmes américain
en tout cas c'est une façon est aussi
connu comme l'irlande c'est plutôt un
facteur de stabilisation et de l'est
donc de sécurité ce qui les a tout à
fait avant merci beaucoup à vous jean
paul chang spécialiste en économie
cofondateur de la lettre de la chine et
avoue frédéric boccara économiste et
membre à des économistes atterrés